ja ob jetzt jamaika oder ich glaube er
die ampel auf jeden fall gibt es ein
thema was nicht nur mich umtreibt was
viele viele millionen bürgerinnen und
bürger umtreibt in diesem land hier
sehen wir das bild einer tankstelle aus
berlin die heute erstmals zwei euro für
den liter sprit verlangt hat zugegeben
da ging es ein bisschen um champagner
benzin das ist also ein besonderes
gewesen aber wir haben auch die anderen
anzeigen gesehen der liter diesel fast 1
60 und superbenzin oder e 10 bei über 1
euro 70 aber benzin es sich das einzige
was in diesen monaten und wochen
besonders teuer geworden ist es geht
auch um das es geht um heizöl aber auch
das tägliche einkaufen 4,1 prozent das
ist die inflationsrate im september
gewesen es gibt experten die sogar für
die nächsten monate bis zu fünf prozent
inflation voraussagen den höchsten wert
seit 28 jahren und es wird mutmaßlich
nicht besser wenn wir uns anschauen was
an co2 umlagen auf gerader
energieträgern wie öl und gas nach oben
drauf kommt dann wird auch das nächste
das übernächste und das übernächste jahr
noch teurer bedeutet die nächste
bundesregierung ist gefordert und was
mich besonders stört ist eigentlich dass
die regierung bisher beim thema
inflation sich eher wegduckt als
aufschreit kein wunder denn sie verdient
kräftig mit beispielsweise über die
mehrwertsteuer beim liter benzin fließen
mittlerweile 90 cent des preises in die
taschen des finanzministers und des
staates also die nächste bundesregierung
mutmaßlich eine von spd grünen und fdp
geführt muss ein stoppschild setzen für
inflation da wo etwas teurer wird da
muss sie auf der anderen seite entlasten
beispielsweise steuern senken und wo
sich kosten gar nicht vermeiden lassen
wie gesagt müssen bürger entlastet
werden anders geht es nicht sonst droht
hier sozialer unfried
die inflation wird zum stress test für
die neue ampel warten da bin ich fest
überzeugt davon weil das nicht aufgeht
klima investitionen steuerentlastung und
darauf schauen dass die preise stabil
bleiben viele leute werden nach diesem
winter ruiniert werden wenn die
gaspreise so ansteigen wenn die benzin
und dieselpreise so einsteigen dann wird
bei vielen am ende des monats nichts
mehr übrig bleiben und dann gehen
investitionen zurück der gt
inlandskonsum zurück und hat das
auswirkungen unserer wirtschaft deswegen
muss die politik sich dieses themas
annehmen muss gegensteuern dass ich sehe
das genau wie sie und nicht der
regierung die jetzt ins amt kommt hat
das als erste hausaufgabe zu erledigen
die haben sie einen mit einer wahren
inflations heuchelei zu tun muss man
sagen auf der einen seite verdient der
staat über die mehrwertsteuer kräftig
mit auf der anderen seite ist ja auch
preistreiber wir sehen dass beim bauen
beispielsweise durch immer härtere
vorschriften wir sehen es aber auch
gerade beim thema energie durch diese
co2 umlage die drauf kommt und da ist
das ein bisschen wedel und sagen ja wir
wissen um die sorgen der menschen das
ist scheinheilig das ist nicht echt
gerade weil der stadt preistreiber auf
der einen seite ist und auf der anderen
seite kräftig mitverdienen kassiert ja
es hat nicht nur preistreiber ist ja
auch regel gebe wenn ich meinen die
leute im flachen land die auf dem dorf
wohnen die sollen keine heizung mehr
haben gas wird immer teurer holz sollen
sie auch nicht verheizen wegen den co2
fußabdruck und pv anlage können die
meisten sich nicht leisten und dann
stehen sie da anfragen sich im winter
wie kriege ich eigentlich mein haus noch
waren und dass diese sorge um 34 und ich
hab auch bei der bundestagswahl eine
rolle gespielt gerade in solchen
regionen dass die leute sich gefragt
haben wo es eigentlich der weg wo die
politik mehr hilft dass ich diesen weg
gehen kann das für eine klimaneutrales
land kommt dass ich mir das aber auch
leisten kann und die sorge dass in einer
tankstelle war sie begründet vor der
wahl als die preise erstmals dann
richtig hoch geschwappt sind das sind
viele schockiert zurückgeblieben wann
haben sie das letzte mal gemerkt das ist
richtig feuer geworden ist gestern also
ich weiß kurz vor weihnachten habe ich
vor glaube ich weniger ist ein euro
schon bisher jetzt weihnachten ja und
sie dann habe ich 15 50 bezahlt vollen
liter diesel und ich bin angewiesen auf
dem motto wie viele menschen das ist
kein luxusprodukt die man irgendwie
jetzt mit dem fahrrad kann das ist auch
freiheit und das sind themen die auch
den wahlen da waren da hat man sie
unterdrückt man wollte nicht darüber
reden schon vor den wahlen wusste man
dass viele leute nicht mal heizung
leisten konnten diesem winter und sie
reden ja über die über die wirtschaft
die wirtschaft ist indirekt betroffen
weil ja die einzelperson nicht mal das
geld haben um einkaufen zu gehen aber es
trifft auch die unsere wird und der
standort deutschland alles wirtschafts
ort dass die firmen nicht mehr weltweit
konkurrenzfähig sind wenn sie so vor
energie bezahlen können und das ist
natürlich fragen die jeder bürger bürger
in diesem land beschäftigen beschäftigen
werden ja ich habe meinen wahlkreis
unternehmen die sind in einer
energieintensiv eine waffelbäckerei für
linien wäre das vielleicht kennt dass
leute die auf ihre ernährung achten
nehmt das produkt ganz gerne einkaufen
das 1 und da ist es so dass die drittel
der kosten sind nur gaskosten weil die
waffeln gebacken werden müssen und der
unternehmer sagt ganz klar irgendwann
kann ich mir das nicht mehr leisten weil
ich kann diesen preis nicht steuern ich
kann da nicht so gesehen hat vielleicht
die union auch ein bisschen dahin gehen
auch von den grünen und vor diesem
klimawandel one auch ein bisschen
geküsst nein die union ist glaube ich
die einzige partei im politischen
spektrum die deutlich sagt wir müssen
beides miteinander in verbindung bringen
es muss möglich sein sagt auch das
stimmt okay an diesem stück kleiner aber
dieser bringt die fdp sagt verbinden so
verbinden dass man nicht mehr sprit
leisten kann nein eben nicht es muss in
beides muss leistbar bleiben trotzdem
ist die klimaziele erreichen deswegen
muss man manche schritte auch langsamer
gehen das ist eben das entscheidende
dass man es machen muss ist es gibt
nicht wie bei der meinungsbildung soll
dieses schwarz oder weiß es muss auch
die möglichkeit geben dass man diesen
weg so geht dass man die leute mitnimmt
und nicht zurück lässt und wenn
verständnis kriegt man doch nur für
politische entscheidungen wie die leute
es nachvollziehen können wenn sie das
für sich auch akzeptieren können dass es
zu ihrem leben gehört wende gefühl es in
berlin wird das entschieden was eine
lebenswirklichkeit zu hause vorbei geht
dann wenden sie sich ab und dann haben
wir genau das wahlverhalten was man auch
gerade in den neuen ländern hätten wir
sehen sie das denn ist es auto freiheit
oder muss man vielleicht auch
persönliche freiheiten müssen
zurücknehmen um dem klimawandel zu legen
ich glaube dass das hippe debatten sind
die wir hier in einer riesigen stadt
führen der ich aus dem haus gehen kann
und fahle eine u-bahn oder in eine s
bahn was auch immer zwei drittel der
deutschen leben aber überhaupt gar nicht
in der stadt sondern leben auf dem land
für die sind weder die hippen lastenrad
debatten weil sie die
50 kilometer zum nächsten bäcker der
schon ans nächste zentrum mitgezogen es
überhaupt gar nicht mehr fahren können
weil dort alte leute leben für die sind
lastenrad debatten einfach auch nicht
und die frage ob sie im bus nehmen die
stellt sich auch nicht weil dort schon
seit jahren keiner mehr fährt mit dieser
kaputten infrastruktur die haben einfach
nur ein auto und dann geht es gar nicht
um freiheit sondern da geht es um die
elementare frage wie komme ich an mein
nächstes brot und da ist alles was wir
hier besprechen die wir sofort in nehme
ich jetzt die busse oder die bahn das
erreicht die nicht carsharing wir reden
ja über das problem ja da kann man noch
mal vielleicht kann man einen den punkt
noch ein bisschen weiter den wir machen
wir erleben natürlich auch jetzt und wir
wissen alle inflation wird am ende
zumindest teilweise gestoppt durch eine
zinspolitik wenn die preise steigen dann
muss normalerweise die notenbank die
zinsen erhöhen um diesen preisschub zu
dämpfen diesen unsozialen preisschub
also inflation ist unsozial und die
notenbank steuert dagegen das tut die
notenbank nicht obwohl sie eigentlich
machen müsste wir haben ja auch auf
europäischer ebene eine inflation die
deutlich zu hoch ist es tut sie nicht
warum tut sie das nicht wir erleben
jetzt die quittung für die
schuldenpolitik der letzten jahre denn
viele viele regierungen haben sich auch
nach der euro krise massiv verschuldet
haben sich im land staatsanleihen
ausgegeben die hat die notenbank kauft
das problem ist jetzt diesen massiv
verschuldet wenn jetzt die zinsen lagen
würden müssten diese regierung
beispielsweise in italien plötzlich
ihren haushalt schrumpfen könnten
weniger ausgeben weil sie plötzlich mehr
wieder für die zinsen ausgeben müssten
also hätten weniger zur verfügung für
sozialleistungen für straßenbau wie auch
immer die regierung haben sich selbst in
eine situation manövriert und die
bürgerinnen und bürger zahlen dafür
jetzt die kosten über hohe inflation die
nicht gestoppt wird durch die notenbank
das ist eine ganz ganz bittere quittung
die jetzt zehn jahre nach ausbruch der
finanzkrise eurokrise jetzt zu schultern
ist absolut bei neuinvestitionen dazu
kommt gerade im klima investitionen weil
genau das thema was man vorher hatten
deswegen muss eine neue koalition auch
darauf achten dass sie die fiskalpolitik
des staates im griff behält sozusagen
nicht weiter ausufern lässt sonst trifft
es das mega hat für die nächsten
generation an der urlaubszeit so er
verhält sich jetzt sehr still in diesen
tagen erst der zuständige finanzminister
ich würde mir ein stärkeres wort
wünschen ich will ein beispiel nennen wo
ich mir auch wünschen würde dass die
verantwortlichen gehen die ampel gehen
wollen ihre meinung sagen wenn wir die
preise an der tankstelle diskutieren
warum wird dann hingenommen dass die
deutsche bahn ihre preise jetzt erhöhen
will ja wenn ich eine alternativ
verschaffen will wenn ich mobilität
verändern will dort wo sie möglich ist
dann muss ich auch darauf achten dass
ich auch die preisgestaltung so mache
dass ich das angebot nicht weg
inflationäre und das tut die deutsche
bahn gerate jeder der umsteigen will hat
keine alternative stellt die heuer ein
neues und erst recht gerade für
stammkunden die bahncard wird ja teurer
erst wird ehrlich zu sagen die leute die
schon umgestiegen sind die kriegen jetzt
ist ganz dicke erst einmal oben drauf
und also gleich finanzminister würde
oder verkehrsminister bahntickets nur
noch halb so teuer bahncard ebenfalls
halb so teuer er definitiv pnv genauso
sind die frage ich muss doch mobilität
erstmal attraktiv machen und das fängt
an mit besseren verbindung das fängt an
das überhaupt verbindung gibt vom dorf
in die stadt dass mobilität möglich ist
dann kann ich da ist die alternativen
machen die politik bespricht er selber
runter darum sie haben genau gesagt wir
reden erst mal die frage wie mache ich
die benzinpreise teurer wie vor wenig
das autofahren wie schaffe ich
parkplätze verlassen verrät aber nicht
mehr für autos mache ich die innenstädte
wie blockiert die auch schaffe keine
alternativen hier in berlin ist es alles
leicht gesagt wer draußen auf dem land
ist sieht wie die lebenswirklichkeit
möglich ist
[Musik]